Chris Davis the Orioles first baseman as
he broke an old 454 slump and he joins
us on the program how fun was that game
where you get three hits at Chris I was
awesome it was long over it was just I
mean it was a cool day for me personally
and then obviously as a team to get the
win in an environment like this in a
place like this and then obviously
against a team like the Red Sox it was
just it was a pretty cool day for
everybody in an Oriole uniform can you
have us do you need to have a sense of
humor to get through something like this
I feel like you do or just cry a lot I
mean I don't know any other way to go
about it there was a kind of a turning
point for me
a couple of weeks ago where I felt like
I just kind of had to embrace it and
trying to have a little bit of fun with
it but at the same time you know
obviously I wanted to take it seriously
and continue to work and do whatever I
could to get get out of it but I mean
it's baseball you know I mean stuff like
this happens hopefully nobody ever has
to go through it quite as long as I did
but uh yeah I mean I think you have to
have a sense of humor to get there
something like that how would you
describe the last month to somebody who
didn't know the story didn't see you
play it was I mean it was a
rollercoaster of emotions for me it was
a lot of anticipation leading up to
opening day and then obviously a lot of
frustration and disappointment the first
week and a half is followed by a huge
weight lifted off my shoulder I think it
was a obviously a sense of relief but I
don't know I mean it was kind of for me
it was it was an encouraging moment to
see my teammate even the even the Red
Sox fans the way everybody reacted and
responded and to hear the encouragement
to hear the positivity from not only our
fans but from from other fans as well it
was uh it was a cool experience that's
for sure
I know that when you're a baseball
player you may say you don't hear things
but baseball players have rabbit ears so
you're in the on-deck circle
or you're at the plate what kind of
conversations comments are you hearing I
mean it's just at first it was a lot of
a euro for whatever David don't strike
out you know like all the like pretty
much all the normal things that I hear
on a day-to-day basis but towards the
end it was actually like hey Chris come
on today's your day but I think there
was an Astros fan that made like a Chris
Davis sign at a Red Sox Orioles game so
it was just trying at that point out I
felt like there were there was something
a little bit bigger going on around me
and and obviously like I said it was it
was cool to get the hit and hear the
cheers from not only our fans but for a
Red Sox fans as well also the worst
thing an athlete can do is think in the
moment you guys are you're such
reactionary type people you know you
prepare for the moment to then just
react and then all of a sudden you get
in your head and you probably were so
deep into your head you didn't know how
to get out of it so what do you do well
I think really the hardest part for me
was trying to quiet everything down
about all the outside always it wasn't
really until about four or five days ago
that I felt like I was making some
progress and I had a few games where I
swear it balls up and had absolutely
nothing to show for it but I felt like
it was really the first time throughout
the street that I was able to kind of
get out of my own head and get on my own
way and I just go out there and play the
game and obviously at this level
everybody's got the talent but the big
separator is being able to deal with the
stress but distractions all that entails
in between your ears on a daily basis
finding some something positive to take
away from every game as they're told me
and you know what makes matters worse
that other
Davis who spells his name differently
than you do kaj killing it I had
somebody say hey I think you were
talking about having Chris Davis on he
homered I go oh that's just our luck
that'll be great you'll be in a great
mood and then I look and I go it's the
damage Chris Davis with a k' yeah I told
him when we played and went and he just
while he went off I think the last game
because he hit two home runs I'm like
all right
I told him I said hey man I appreciate
you keeping a good name Davis name it's
awesome yeah you know it's it is what it
is
at this point in my career I'm really
just I don't feel like I'm kind of son
Saida Swiper or caught off-guard by too
much just kind of haven't been through a
lot of stuff yeah throughout my career
who you facing today at Fenway we are
facing Velasquez our two ladies there at
seven field right now and are you on the
field now I'm going on I'm in the dugout
oh that's a little drizzle nice and cool
overcast 11 o'clock game pretty fun
sounds like good Danny hit a home run
[Laughter]
maybe you just change the spelling of
your name and then people don't know the
difference here okay my bad my bad
we're talking to the red-hot Chris Davis
of the Orioles he's got the Red Sox
coming up today you know through all of
it
and I and I cringed when you came to the
plate I mean I thought it was so painful
cuz I just can't imagine what that's
like cuz you can't hide in baseball when
you go to the plane and you maintained
your
nationalism so through it all as
difficult and usually that's what you
know starts to fall to the wayside so I
I applaud you for doing that I'm glad
you got a couple of knocks and hopefully
it's the start Chris thank you that's
Chris Davis chri yes that other damn
Chris Davis of Oakland for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app